let's talk about the foods to counter obesogens so
what is an obesogen well it is those things in the
environment that don't have to do with calories
they have to do with man-made chemicals that
contribute to being obese i'm talking about things
that are food containers that you maybe will put
in the microwave baby bottles toys plastics and
their related chemicals cookware as in nonstick
teflon and even cosmetics now what do all these
have in common well they give off chemicals that
mimic estrogen and estrogen is one of those
hormones that make you fat so let's go through
some of the chemicals you have bisphenol a bpa
which is one of those chemicals found in different
plastics then you have phthalites which are also
in plastics in other containers and atrazine which
is the most widely used herbicide so it's in our
food unless you do organic then you have other
chemicals like pfoa which you're normally going
to see in those non-stick pans like teflon then
you have des diethylstilbestrol now that's a drug
that has been banned but apparently it's still
in our environment to a certain degree then you
have ssris which are serotonin selective reuptake
inhibitors better known as antidepressants and
this is why one of the side effects is waking so
let's get to the solutions one of the things
that you need to do is just be aware of what
chemicals do what thus this video and number two
there are certain foods that you can start to eat
that will slowly detoxify estrogen from your
body using the hub of detoxification which is
the liver and so your liver has the ability to
turn these poisons into harmless particles it's
called phase one phase two detoxification and
to stimulate more of this detoxification process
the cruciferous vegetables are the best
solution now the second solution is probiotics
because the more diversified microbes you
have in your gut the better you're going
to be able to deal with these poisons now
if we combine probiotics with cruciferous
we get sauerkraut and we also get fermented
vegetables which are really good because they
provide the prebiotics the fiber as well as the
probiotics so just make sure you have some of
these foods in your diet on a regular basis so you
cannot just protect yourself from getting fat but
to avoid these chemicals that create a lot of
other issues so if you're enjoying my content
which i hope you are and you're applying this
knowledge to your health and you have a success
i'd really appreciate you sharing your
success story so click the link down below
to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others